the Joe Rogan experience hasten to what
you know when people are masons
everybody freaks out I'm so ignorant I
don't really know what that is but I see
it all the time what's an ancient group
that you could be long - and I know but
they still have I know that but I mean
it's still happening today I don't
understand who's who becomes a Mason
today isn't Michael Chevelle owes a
Mason and I think Pat Miletich is a
Mason as well someone else Randall
Carlson how do you write how do you go
through it what do you is there like a
fraternal [ __ ] oh no I think it's
like some guy explaining to me once in
Houston some dude and he seemed pretty
honest he's like yeah it's [ __ ] guys
club you hang out yes like the rotary
it's like some secret [ __ ] it's gone on
forever never he goes but it's nothing
it's mostly just a place where guys hang
out they say that that's planning some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] though that's that's
really where people plants everything
don't worry about us it's not that
government takeover type show yeah yeah
yeah yeah who do we talk to in the car
that said that they were saying they
think oh that they was talking about
Snowden saying that he's oh yeah
controlled opposition rolled opposition
that term that term bugs the [ __ ] out of
me yeah cuz I've heard it so many times
used about me
you're controlled opposition yeah that's
what I did my entire life what I did was
I got into martial arts I became a
martial arts guy taught martial arts got
in a stand-up comedy but it's really
just to become controlled opposition
yeah all of it this career you know
putting together a podcast all that
talking [ __ ] smoking weed with Elon Musk
it's just controlled opposition it was
just a long single play a long play it's
basically the Chinese government got to
hold me when I was baby and they groomed
me did yeah oh yeah yeah I didn't know
yeah yeah control opposition thing is
when people on the outside you know have
you ever had someone like come up with a
theory about you that you read it you
like what I'm gay according the Internet
that's my that's my favorite I'm gay
because I said on a post one time that I
married Chris D'Elia that we were like
running away and like a foreign
publication got ahold of it that like
that's the English translations
hysterical what do you think the
original language was
I don't have a wine was born it was
before just for him just foreign foreign
foreign but it just says I'm gay if you
look it up his Andrew Santino gay it
says a lot of things say I'm gay
congratulations yeah I'm actually kind
of stoked about if you get would you be
a top or a bottom I'd be a power bottom
power what is a power I push back you
know I mean okay we were boots rust hard
yeah grips and [ __ ] gloves
we're fingerless gloves I slam back
right like the kind that guys work out
in the park you know those guys work
gloves yeah there I am I've got your
sentido married with wife or gay man bio
hints what sexuality might be live
ramped up that's the name of the website
look at you and alia Oh area yeah that
is let you look getting that picture I
know oh my god you look like you're
looking at dick I'm home I'm so hungry
for it so I guess I am
mmm what you don't do at least you're
not controlled opposition I am though
you're both mm-hmm a gay controlled
position knees yeah I've been I'm a
government experiment
[Applause]